highly-anticipated grand jury report
detailing alleged abuses by hundreds of
Catholic priests across Pennsylvania is
set to be released later today the first
statewide report will reveal accusations
against more than 300 so-called Predator
priests and reported efforts by church
leaders to cover them up the former
bishop of pittsburgh Cardinal Donald
Wuerl is expected to come under intense
scrutiny for how he handled more than
two dozen abuse cases
Nicky batiste has been following the
abuse scandal and spoke with Cardinal
Wuerl in an interview you'll see only on
CBS this morning she's at the
Pennsylvania State Capitol in Harrisburg
Nicky good morning good morning Cardinal
Wuerl created support programs for
survivors and a zero tolerance policy
against abusive priests with this grand
jury reports released just a few hours
away here world maintains his responsive
to abuse cases in the Pittsburgh diocese
were appropriate if there were
allegations we dealt with him
immediately Cardinal Donald Wuerl
believes the Pennsylvania grand jury
investigation will vindicate the reforms
he championed in 2002 to rid the
Catholic Church of abusive priests about
a third of the people accused in this
report are from the Pittsburgh diocese
some people have called for your
resignation do you have any plans to
resign it goes back over 70 years so I
think we have to be realistic and say
this this claim that goes back over
decades in decades
did you ever move priests quietly to
another that wasn't that wasn't our our
process in 2007 afterworld became
Archbishop of Washington the Pittsburgh
diocese he led agreed to pay 1.25
million dollars to settle lawsuits filed
by 35 abuse survivors how does it feel
knowing children were sexually abused at
the hands of priests under your watch
well that's why if that came to the
light we moved to remove that priest
we're very very sorry this happened and
that's why we've taken this
to see that it doesn't go on what are
the steps because I think a lot of
victims will say we've heard this before
almost more than a decade ago and now we
have that charter in place which
provides for all kinds of background
checks last month a man Worrell
succeeded in Washington Theodore
McCarrick was suspended by Pope Francis
after accusations he sexually abused
altar boys and adult seminarians decades
ago were you aware of the rumors
mckarrick was having relationships with
other priests no I know do you think
right now today children are being
abused at the hands of priests in the
Catholic Church I'm not sure that
there's any way you can guarantee that
there won't ever be a failure in the
life of any priest going into the future
you can't do more than give you a very
best to trying to eradicate a problem
the pittsburgh diocese and the five
others under investigation have already
received the grand jury report the
Cardinal Wuerl tells us he has not
several survivors have come here to
Harrisburg for the reports public
release today they will meet with
Pennsylvania's Attorney General Josh
Shapiro who led this 18-month
investigation
biana great work Nicki thank you so much
for bringing the story to light and
interesting to hear the Cardinal really
defending his actions all these years